I'm not living like this bro I'm not
living like this that's immune but
subtitles
I can't read my own fight then and there
we have to meet in the middle what's all
of that about
[Music]
so you already know guys we hit straight
from the jump with the IG question and
the question this week was what's the
wildest thing you found or seen in
someone else's house
okay
I thought you were going to land on that
phone again no that was a dangerous
episode we're not ready for running back
yet that was a dangerous episode yeah
someone else's house
his ex under his bed ah I promise you
now nah that's not a thing he's X under
his bed bro first of all I'm jumping at
my skin
I'm jumping out my skin exactly how are
you knowing to check under the bed for
anything facts bro as well but it
depends on the angle it also depends on
the distance where the bed was from the
door sometimes you can see stuff under
there as soon as you walk in I just also
think like
it was It was obviously pre-planned like
she was there dude trying to do a thing
the main thing came over and she's like
hide babes hide under the bed is the
first thing before and he's going to be
because mandam Khan we can't really
handle that level of stress his face
told the whole story before she came in
the door
what's wrong
babe what's wrong I could see they're
signing off let's go to your room
yes literally let's look forward bro
that's hilarious I should squeeze it
back yeah yeah exactly what my head was
at
he had one light bulb for the whole
house so you had to bring it to each
room no he didn't
that's because that thing will pop on
you facts yeah yeah yeah oh one label
for the whole house that's the level of
policy I've never even heard of saying
because light bulbs really aren't that
deep
candles what do you mean we're moving
the light yeah that that makes no sense
yeah that's oh that's horrible Jesus all
over the place the bathroom door above
the bed everywhere
okay that's intense that is very
of course it's different as well
obviously it's there you are so they can
do what they want with their yard just
don't invite me next time
I also have some self-awareness yeah
this is too much it is it is this is too
much bro it is it is but he knows he
knows how you feel
so I mean you might not active you're
going to heaven knows how you feel bro
why are we doing all this Haley Gates
here is going to Spud you all your car
yeah
I said he knows
pictures of all her exes next to her bed
so she can insult them before she goes
to sleep thing is
that one doesn't even surprise me
doesn't it based on what we just said in
the patreon episode about the names
they've got for these men oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah they don't give stuff up yeah
yeah women love to resent their exes
yeah man them just move on we literally
move on but I know one Brett who is the
exception to that rule I'm not gonna
bait him out he's an avid listener and I
hope he knows I'm talking to him when
his when this episode drops yeah I want
my what's that to pick yeah because he
knows he needs to know what he's doing
okay he's been pulled up on his behavior
more than once I'm tired of hearing it I
swear bro he chats about his baby mama
with disrespect you've met this guy and
I'll tell you who is off cam yeah I'm
trying to think if I know who it is
daily disrespect okay yeah and we have
to tell him get over it okay I don't
like hearing this kind of stuff say less
yeah yeah I love to do it they love to
do it all right what's the wildest thing
you've seen or found in someone else's
house
after a month of dating I cleaned his
house and found underwear nose rings and
her toys
underwear nose rings and her toys
man didn't even bother cleaning up after
after his ex
just just left everything and she
cleaned ah nose rings is specific as
hell yeah that's niche as hell yeah does
she live here she must what do you mean
those Rings comfortable there's
underwear and nose rings and there's
toys they're big man she's comfortable
yeah she's comfortable wow wow okay cool
chickens no [__] chickens running
through their house imagine it I can't
imagine that because you know
you know that's my West fat
I couldn't what would you actually do
because I know I'd hear them before they
see them
all I'd hear is that
what is that what the [__] is that yeah
I know that I know the noise is
triggering for me what is that tell me
it's the TV I'm walking out bro
what if what if you've gone in right you
hear it let's say okay let's say you've
gone into someone's here let's say my
art for example yeah right you know what
my layout's like you've gone to the
spare bathroom you've gone to piss or
whatever you come out
doors locked don't even think about
going to the door you come on you go
back to the list
from the outside
you come back I'm I'm in the I'm in the
balcony and I've locked in from the
outside so it was just human chickens in
the living room what are you doing just
you and chickens Bro you've gone toilet
and I've just released them why would
you first of all what kind of sick how
are you bro why would you do that to me
I just want to know what you'll do you
know what I do I'd find a way out
I'm finding a way out bro I'll run
through the door I said don't even
bother looking I'm I'm getting out bro
I locked myself back in that same toilet
I promise you if I knock myself back at
that same toilet and call the ambulance
I'll call the fire department bro I want
to get my hands on you I'll claw your
face off
that week because I wouldn't be able to
close your fist I'll claw your face off
I'll be so angry
I'll leave on you and start clawing at
you bro [__] that will drag me off
wow wow you can't do stuff like that oh
that's too funny my grandma's calendar
marked sex on July 26th
nah brother
because you can't even
it's there she's done told you where it
is bro I was watching First Dates
literally yesterday was one old thing on
there
one old thing
said um
what did she say she said uh when I say
old I mean like 80. and the British was
with 80 and she was just talking mad
sexual bro and she was saying how like
she was like on her date she was like
not gonna lie to you I've Got a Friend
she said this she said this to her date
okay I said we're not too old but I've
got she said you're as young as you feel
I'm not gonna lie to you I've got a
friend I've got a friend who knows how
to please me
and he comes over now and again
oh fan okay I'm with you yeah he said
friend I thought she meant for them too
to laugh she said in my personal I
forgot friend okay who knows my body and
knows what I like okay who knows my body
say less he said she's he's an F buddy
okay and the brave fan he kept eye
contact yeah I bet he kept icons
and he had like fat Dentures I said he
couldn't close his mouth
one lazy artist
he's a kid yeah yeah I'm gonna tear that
up oh wait I'm gonna tear down oh my God
it was crazy bro a room full of Michael
B Jordan posters
in 2023 that there's a plenty of room to
fill it up in 2023 Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah
Yeah with his wife busy be wearing
a framed picture of me that I never gave
them hanging on their wall
imagine you walk into a spice's yard or
potential Link's yard and you've got a
picture of they've got a picture of
yourself hanging there you've never
given them this picture bro
they've just hacked site they found it
somewhere your Instagram somewhere
and it's just hanging though you know
because you're in two minds as well
because you know the throat's gonna be
yeah [__] nuts
yeah
I will stand there yeah
yeah I think wow right I need to dip at
the same time yeah yeah she idolizes man
let me let me try start let me test the
waters
let me make her dreams come true
in fact I might as well I'm here I'm
here if I leave it's pointless bro she's
probably got booby traps on the way out
I'm locked in fact let me guess like
that is before I lose my life
wow she idolizes me yeah
[Laughter]
bro she idolizes me that's the funniest
Barber
so manipulative that's horrible oh God
that's funny oh God
foreign
oh because I know it's just me and you
yeah yeah yeah and this joke but there's
hundreds of thousands of people
listening and watching to this and it
makes me laugh
oh God it's funny
hilarious hilarious oh God go on all
right but I got a few more something
real quick say less wildest thing you've
seen or found in someone else's house my
ex kept his mother's teeth in a drawer
she died when he was four years old he
put some suckers in sometimes I know he
does oh
condoms in the middle of her Bible like
a bookmark
again
frequently yeah that's in the Bible yeah
she doesn't care she doesn't she does
she likes to play with fire if she lives
to play with with Hellfire yeah she
likes to play with Hellfire she's stuck
in the middle she doesn't know which
side yeah
my neighbor's still wiping her 11 year
old son's ass
you can get paper route bro wow that's
funny wow
phlegm on the bedside table man couldn't
be bothered to get up and go to his
bathroom
one of my boys had no shame growing up
boy oh my God Hey whenever you had colds
yeah you'd find a bottle of phlegm next
to his bed a bottle of it bro that's
this it was disgusting file that is
disgust vile bro but when you're pulling
up he's like I'm not getting out of bed
at three I'm not doing I'm spitting it
somewhere bro yeah but you have to be so
precise that yeah you have to percolate
your lips
yeah last but not least they ate
spaghetti and meatballs straight out of
the can
that's actually disgusting actually no
someone I know who would do that as well
really yeah
um don't want to Beta do I want to pay
uh to be fair she's not ashamed of it so
beta Jade who we play Warzone with
yeah she loves eating stuff at cams bro
beans sure she said her favorite snack
is cold beans out of the can baked beans
yeah what yeah she loves it yeah she
rides for it bro she don't give a [__]
she loves silly stuff like that real
quick before we move on before you do
the intro obviously I said I said
Fleming um like two sentences ago
can you man smell phlegm for me
I'm gonna go with p h l e g m
that's right p h l e m close wait you
guys are both right yeah let's go say
less bro well done Ram let's go bro
let's go
um intro right guys what is going on
welcome back welcome back and um very
very excited to to have you here
um The Log Cabin tour is in full swing
and we are vibing with you man first
half of the tour first half of the tour
fantastic it's been Sensational so again
thank you to literally everybody who
came to show face showed love and
support and um yeah man it is
truly a surreal World we're living in
before every show me if we had to look
at each other would clink our glasses
and think what kind of stupid life is
this just soak it all up man just soak
it in man it's good but anyway we're
here it's another beautiful Monday and
um guys you already know what to do if
uh you want the Log Cabin culture to
continue if you want to be indoctrinated
into the cult babies what you need to do
is head on over to patreon.com forward
slash shits and gigs it's going to cost
you basically nothing but we can't
charge nothing so we charge three pound
a month MP a day so run the pita SMG and
get three and a half years worth of
content facts you're gonna get
um access to our Discord Channel where
all the cult babies congregate facts and
uh you're going to get early access to
episodes you're gonna get discount on
the merch that is soon to drop
and uh all the other perks
um and uh Early Access discounts All
That Jazz you know what it is and then
um
if you're watching us on YouTube guys
please subscribe to the channel more
than anything I'm not gonna ask you to
do anything else if you want to chirps
things in the comments that's on you we
want you to do it but I'm not going to
ask you to do it this time just sub to
the channel because we need a golden
plaque we need the gold one silver is
for like I read this some one time
silver is for
still was basically for white people
okay because they have a Bluey tint
some people suit silver some people suit
gold oh okay so if you have a ready
yellowy tin in your skin okay gold
bubbles on you it looks good yeah yeah
silver doesn't do too well you would
look terrible in silver as would I the
whites they sue silver there's nothing
wrong with it yeah but they suit the
100K stuff yeah yeah your boy suit the
Millies so we need the Millies yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah we need that gold because
it makes our skin pops and our it makes
our eyes look more Hazelnut and
chocolatey [__] so run it yeah fat and
we can't just get it let's run this up
it's down to you man um literally down
to you guys and guys if you're listening
on the Audio Apps you guys have done so
much for us we appreciate you I want to
give you I'm doing flowers all round
today I want to give you guys flowers
you guys have put us on billboards you
guys have put us on like charts in the
biggest charts in the world you guys
have like made our lives a possibility
so please continue to do that follow the
channel and um give us a nice review if
uh possible and before I wrap up the
intro today yeah yeah
I told you I'm giving flowers all around
I remember a while ago when I was doing
appreciation introductions added
everyone yeah but I was on the drive-in
today I was having some reflect yeah
reflective thoughts yep and I'm gonna
give Ram flowers again oh let's go
let's go random flowers yeah yeah so REM
actually doesn't know it's this applies
to all my close friends but like REM
is possibly like you know that film that
you love inside out
with the emotions yeah yeah yeah that
film now so Vegas
inside out where you have the core
memories yep there's certain pivotal
moments in your life that will Define
you forever yeah
REM is one of those things there's a
thing in my head and in my heart yeah
and in my soul that's just a little ball
with like rem's [__] cheesy grin on
it yeah yeah so not many people know
this right part of the reason that I'm
able to do a job like this and be so
expressive and uh just entirely myself
is literally because of him okay so when
I was growing up right I was obviously
I've said this before on here before
bedtime's I just had an Eclectic group
of friends an Eclectic group in music
taste film taste everything yeah but I
couldn't be myself because all my
bedrooms were black okay and mixed race
okay and then I wasn't allowed to listen
to rock I wasn't allowed to listen to
metal I wasn't allowed to listen to
Indie [__] I wasn't allowed to watch
Indie shows I wasn't allowed to dress
like a skateboarder like I wanted to I
wasn't allowed to start skateboarding
like I wanted to I wasn't allowed to do
white [__] I just had to do black [__]
so I have to keep all that [__] secret
so none of my boys knew that
um I was listening to half for the
musicians I was listening to I remember
trying to even bridge the gap with any
Rd bro trying to bring the Neptunes to
my boys was a lockdown thing Pharrell's
name he was just white to them
skateboard P was just white to them
hey boy P yeah he was my idol okay these
men were just like that's just white
stuff yeah shut up
bro you couldn't yeah it's a good time
bro you could you weren't allowed yeah
yeah so I'll just vibing to this in
private yeah yeah I'm out here listening
to Tenacious D comity rock yeah do you
think I could bring comedy Rock to my
bridges yeah never in a million years so
just shut all of it down
then I came to UNI met yuman day one
and from the jump this bastard is black
yeah he runs a BMX everywhere yeah he
did he did he wears Vans everywhere
facts he did
he still does still does yeah loves him
some fans he plays ball which is sick
loves anime
put me onto different anime he was the
first person that I actually felt
confident being like I watch anime yeah
yeah yeah yeah because you guys had the
um we had the Naruto headbands bro yeah
oh what a day I'll never forget the day
of my life yeah okay and um and again
when we lived together it wasn't until
we moved in together where he was he had
the room next door yes a man's banging
out Paramore yeah man's bringing out
Blink-182 yeah man and then we took it
even further and he's um we connected on
like Guitar Hero [__] we're talking
about Metallica songs we're talking
about uh what's it what's that stricken
uh Disturbed we're talking about
Slipknot bro we're talking about all
these things that I spent my entire life
being shunned for yeah yeah and it's the
first black bear in my life who I can
just be like
you watch your South Park as much as I
want South Park he's just into
everything that I'm into pause and
it was just like wow this was like a
core point in my life where I actually
felt comfortable to be myself okay and
now that I have backup I can start
telling you get on anime yeah and shut
up I would have never had the ball to do
that before Okay and like even little
things where like we will come together
and like we had to keep going to all
these black Graves all the time yes yes
and then and then me and him were just
chat and I would like be like bro I mean
should we just you'd whisper yeah hit me
up
My Chemical Romance
does slap and I heard there's a phone
party on Thursday I say we just don't
tell them and we just go there's a white
rave on Wednesday bro let's just go and
not tell anyone see what it's saying see
what it's saying yeah I'll tell you what
he was saying bro it was one of the
largest nights till day bro I remember
you man that first phone party was the
first White River we've ever been to it
was just bro it was just Fall Out Boy
yeah and
okay
and the thing as well is Vibes with that
man stop uh they start incredibly early
we got there early and it was packed
yeah yeah that's that's the thing I
found 50 pound on the floor that day
these white people just dropped my yeah
they don't care they don't care about
money bro I found 50 pound that day that
was a night it was a night bro I've
never had a night like it before or
since and that's literally all thanks to
this guy yeah yeah and then moving
forward I've just been so authentically
myself in every situation because I'm
like someone's gonna resonate I'm tired
of being like Oh that's why stuff I saw
stuff that's this I'm just gonna be
let's do what I want and if people like
it they like it and if they don't like
it it actually doesn't really matter
um so Props to Ram thank you bro
literally changed my life anytime
literally changed my life that's gone so
sick Bro yeah man I love that love that
love that are we ready
yeah right guys so apparently there's a
score correction and thank you guys for
like pointing that out Jimmy's on four
Rams on three yes Sir Ellis is on two
top five top five top five today is
drum roll please
highest selling artists of all we knew
it when you before you were here we
guessed it yeah because I know you must
say the other week yeah we guessed it
yeah uh this one we weren't too stressed
about this one right highest setting
artists of all time of all time not
albums not singles artists yeah when
your man are locked in let me know and
they'll run it and obviously as per
usual I'll give you ten to one as
opposed to five to one okay right I'm
scared are we locked yes yes cool uh
Ellis you go first then Michael Jackson
yep Queen yep oh Queen Abba yep
then this way I fumbled a bit I did
Beyonce and I did Drake
I don't think they're in top five uh I
wouldn't say top top five but they're
the only ones I could think of after
cool uh ramp okay so I've gone Michael
Jackson
I've gone Rolling Stones I was thinking
Rolling Stones good shout I've gone
Beatles Madonna
and also I might regret it but because
Alice is Beyonce so I'll just take the L
on there I'll I want to say Elvis
damn James didn't even think about Elvis
honorable mentions are drinking it's
hard to lose in this game my honorable
mentions so now I've changed Beyonce to
Elvis and my honorable mentions now
become Beyonce Drake and Eminem
okay cool shot uh right I've done three
honorable mentions give me those first
Bad Bunny okay One Direction okay and
BTS
fair if I can play yeah those yeah they
sell [__] yeah all three of them I
forgot about this right so top five yeah
yeah Drake yeah Michael Jackson yeah the
Beatles MJ Beatles yeah Taylor Swift
and Beyonce see swizzy my heart's
pounding bro that's a good one all right
Ellis you've gone with MJ Queen Abba
Beyonce Drake The Ram you've gone for MJ
Rolling Stones Beatles Madonna Elvis
is such a good show you've gone for
Drake Michael Jackson Beatles Taylor
Swift Beyonce number 10 Led Zeppelin
uh AC DC Metallica yeah yeah yeah number
nine Elton John I was gonna put Elton
John in there number nine do you want to
put Elton no no
number eight Frank Sinatra good shout
out very good shout great show number
seven
Pink Floyd oh wow I never would have put
Pink Floyd in there number six
Rolling Stones
close but no cigar so now five to one
yeah number five
Madonna damn it so rem's got one so far
damn bro well played let's go number
four
Queen oh yeah
okay wow you actually murking me number
three
[Music]
it's actually wrapped number two Beatles
MJ yeah mji of course okay everyone got
MJ MJ and number one
The Beatles REM got four out of five
bang let's go let's go let's actually go
let's roll the six as well oh my days
let's go so REM got four out of five
Jimmy got one out of five I got two
Ellis what's the second one you got
Michael Jackson Bills beat your sorry
yes you're right sorry Eris you got two
two as well so REM win so it's four four
two yeah Drake's not in the top ten
Thriller albums from A2
so I get it I get it it's the time it's
the time he's sold so yeah well done REM
thank you top five done four four two
we'll see what happens next week Alice
awesome me and remember even now I've
just been taking else for like the last
five weeks you've been on four in a
minute now you've been on four for a
minute now say less give me something
bro give us how to sink my teeth into
oh God that's really frustrating
I know it has but you're not saying you
every day damn okay cool
um in the spirit of uh giving flowers
I've got a real quick uh Creator
appreciation I haven't done one of these
in like over a year I think uh create
air appreciation for this week is a guy
on Tick Tock that I'm sure everyone's
seen his name is Keith Lee
he does food reviews oh so he does food
reviews yeah yeah all right he actually
was a professional fighter I thought he
was trying pop in his thing is it better
with the plaits yeah I thought so and he
talks like this and he has the camera
yeah and he's like yeah yeah yeah yeah
he says like this yeah I'm going to be
very honest about this review he did it
where he just did um Kevin Hart's yeah
exactly so basically Keithley
very religious prayer as well okay
um I spent the last like year or two
just doing like daily food reviews for
places so people emailing and message
him try this place try this place try
this place try this place try this place
uh and he does his best to give his most
honest opinion of everything and he
gives it like a rate out of 10. so give
like the chips are written out of ten to
get the burger rating out of 10 who
gives the source for rate now 10 gives
everything right now 10 and then like an
overall rating for his experience cool
uh it gets rated for like the customer
service the price everything
um and he's put himself in a position I
think he's got like 12 or 13 mil on Tick
Tock okay uh and he's in a position now
where like people trust this prayer over
anything yeah
um
so to piggyback on what you just said he
literally just did a review for Kevin
Hart for his heart house burger that
opened up the same one yeah the same one
that opened up any uh did you hear the
phone call
um between Kevin he recorded the phone
call of Kevin asking him to do it okay
um and said
is the one opposite Chick-fil-A yeah
yeah and we're open on Sundays oh okay
yes
so he even said like I don't know why
Kevin's asked me to do this yeah because
he's probably got enough publicity
around this anyway he doesn't need me to
go in and Slaughter his Burger because
it's a vegan joint yeah yeah yeah he's a
vegan joint so this guy was like I don't
like vegan joints so I'm sorry I'm gonna
give it a review that I want to give
yeah yeah Kevin Hart was like gang do
what you need to do
gave a shining review said the burger
was banging let's go said the burger was
baggy fatal do they look banging yeah
they do look like and I don't like
faking meat stuff so I'll be very very
surprised so I'm very intrigued about
this hot house Burger whatever it is
called hot house yeah yeah
um but yeah I just think this guy's very
cool and and
um what he has done as well is like a
lot of his reviews have like saved
restaurants really he's getting to the
point now where like people were
emailing and just be like look
um I really want to come to our
restaurant I don't care about the review
I think the food is great my dad's been
my dad's had a stroke and he's still
here every day the sir like we're only
getting through like 20 people a day and
we're really really struggling can you
just come through and do a review and if
it's good great if it's not fine we'll
deal with it it is we're not getting
customers anyway and it'll go there and
like again he gives his honest opinion
and then sometimes he gives like a like
a raven review and bang their restaurant
starts popping because my man's head is
good
and he always thanks God between before
every video okay thanks a lot for the
position that he's in for every video
bro yeah um yeah yeah super
super generous super honest and very
very like
as boring as he is to watch because he's
always so dry and plain I can't get
enough of his videos I swear I watch him
all the time fair enough so yeah I want
to give him his flowers today because he
is literally doing the Lord's work yeah
he is he is he's like saving [__]
businesses and I'm sure he's plummeting
some of them as well with the bad
reviews but hey if it's bad honesty yeah
if it's bad then it's bad bad bro he's
not the only person that thinks he's bad
he must not be the only person I think
is bad oh facts bro yeah yeah 100 so it
is what it is man and um yeah I just
thought it was cool I just thought it
was really really really cool and I like
um I like watching him and what I'll
also like about it is he's getting so
famous yeah but his production level is
us okay he's just the phone in his car
he always is in his car okay it's just
the phone there and like he does these
really awkward Zoom ins okay which
pissed me off yeah and like everything
about is terrible yeah the audio is
terrible the the pacing is terrible like
the editing is terrible everything is
terrible but it's such good content that
none of that matters and it's just like
that's all they were here for is a
review I don't care about the Aesthetics
bro for the review literally I don't
care if I can just hear you crumpling
this bag in the microphone which is
annoying me like like nails on a
chalkboard yeah it doesn't matter I'm
here for the content tell me what I want
to hear facts um and I go or not I want
to know it's down the road I want to
know if I can go yeah yeah yeah so bro
it's um
it's it's so good okay it's generally
generally so good and it just reminds me
of that like Tick Tock is making careers
for people for acts bro it's a wholesome
app it's the best it's doing stuff that
other apps haven't done before no one's
been able to this is it's an SEO now
it's a search engine yeah yeah facts
it's a [__] search engine yeah bro
when people want to find out what's good
and what's not people just head up tick
tock tick tock what to do with bro every
time I'm like hearing people that are
like flying over to England or flying
over something they're just like oh I
just went on Tick Tock to see like best
things to do in Thailand or whatever and
you just find the latest [__] to do it's
crazy bro not like these TripAdvisor
little things exactly will tell you what
the weather real shits are acts facts
yeah it's banging bro yeah so so cool
so yeah props to Keith Lee doesn't need
this publicity he's smashing it but
props to him
um he's absolutely killing it dang yeah
so yeah Fair Play Man fair play fair
enough man right guys just give us your
ears for two seconds while we educate
you on the Goliath in male grooming
which is manscape guys so manscape is
dedicated to helping you increase your
confidence and level up your full body
grooming game with the performance
package 4.0 listen up the kit comes with
the essential lawnmower 4.0 which is a
waterproof cordless body trimmer and a
ton of other liquid formulations to
round out your grooming routine whether
you're trimming your chest or your
treasure chest in your pants this is the
best trimmer on the market their trimmer
features the ceramic blade designed to
cut hair on loose skin and reduce
grooming accidents thanks to their
Advanced Skin safe technology guys you
already know the drill so repeat repeat
repeat you need to take action guys head
on over to masgate.com and use the code
sng Sierra November Golf and that's
going to give you 20 off and free
shipping head on over and let's head
back to the episode thank you very much
um you've got a movie recommendation
I've got two movie recommendations I'll
say less we've not done this in a while
but Apple TV don't miss bro they really
don't I watched two of their movies back
to back all right say this I'm Ready the
first one I watched Tetris
what Tetris oh this is the thing I told
you about Tick Tock the other week yeah
when we were doing top five he mentioned
it oh yeah yeah I didn't know where this
movie was say that full TV Tetris the
same brand that I did Blackbird or
whatever it's called yeah yeah his name
is Taryn egerton movie really yeah it's
basically
um air but Tetris oh you see what I'm
saying
the trials and tribulations these men
went through just to get Tetris because
Tetris was um
anyway
it was created in Germany so it's by a
German
um Coda or whatever oh okay he created
it in his spare time it was one of those
ones where he like coded during the day
and created games at night okay and
do you know the reason why it's called
Tetris
no you want me to tell you John watch
the movie
I don't care it's just yeah she could
tell me because I actually don't care
yeah yeah so Tetris is um is a play on
two words Tetra which means four so
obviously the tetris is four blocks in
different arrangements and he loved
tennis so he just called it Tetris it's
got nothing to do with the fair but you
just loves tennis yeah you play with his
kids
um but because obviously Russia is a
communist country
these men weren't allowed to make profit
on anything from Germany I meant Russia
okay Germany except that I meant Russia
all right Google Google
he's Russian
um communist country they can't
obviously profit on anything whatever so
everything goes back to the government
yeah
um so he couldn't profit on that but
there was a lot of sneaky [__] coming it
happening behind the doors in terms of
the um the KGB running up and running up
on my man saying
um you can't you can't sell this stuff
or you can't um you can't publicize this
with without going through US kind of
thing okay so it's all like agree type
thing but honestly
um the main guy's name is Hank um Hank
in the movie
um he's he lives in Japan but he's he's
also a coder and a gamer as well okay
but he didn't he wasn't the one that
invented or created Tetris obviously but
he's once he saw the game he was [__]
addicted to it he was like this is going
to be the greatest thing that's ever
happened he foresaw it and he went he
tried to go to it starts off with him in
his bank narrating the story yeah
um and he's asking he's basically long
story he's asking his Banker for more
money but the banker doesn't know he's
asked for money yet he's going for the
whole story saying how
um someone wanted to buy the game off
him for like 500 bags and the bank was
gasoline let's celebrate let's [__]
sell him yeah like but I said no I said
no Google I want three mil off you okay
so we can do bits yeah yeah yeah
there's so many different I didn't
notice but there's so many different
lights licensing things that you have to
go through like arcade handheld
um all these different things to have
this game licensed in different
countries yeah yeah
but yeah the weight is it's like a
two-hour movie but the way it's like
paced is perfect okay and the way it's
the way it's directed and shot as well
yeah because they add like game elements
to it because obviously the game is a
Tetris is a game it's it's just well
done hang on all right I'm ready well
done I'm ready I'm ready for Apple TV
guys Tetris really really good
recommendation I'll probably give it
like a a four out of five in my opinion
okay the second movie is called I think
it's called sharper yeah the second
movie is called sharper and this so this
is about con artists oh I love movies
about con artists bro but it's twisted
Okay cool so if it starts off with a um
a brother called Tom Tom is played by
Justice Smith you would have seen it's
the brother from the get down do you
remember on Netflix the like 1970s thing
the last thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
you know as well
um but
so it starts off with Tom and Tom's in
like a he he's in a library he loves
books and a chick walks in they start
talking talking they start obviously
talking about the love of books and blah
blah blah and they eventually start
dating they eventually start like living
this happy-go-lucky life but it's in
such a small space of time
that everything is so elevated
that it's like oh my God I can't believe
this person has been out of my life or
whatever for like a lesbian relationship
bro they were just yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
but long story short
um his thing needed P for her brother of
course she did also she also yeah of
course she did so we thought yeah yeah
so it starts off your Tom's story so
they break it down into five different
stories but they all connect okay start
off with Tom story and the chick he was
dating or he is dating it's called
Sandra but she calls herself Sandy so
when
at the end of Tom's story you hear Tom
screaming sandy sandy sandy because
obviously the money situation and then
it skips and it says Sandra so it's
Sunday story okay then you see her
backstory okay cool and then it went up
bro her backstory that goes on to a
Sebastian's story
yeah so yeah this is Apple TV again it's
Apple TV as well another really good
movie sharper and uh sharper and Tetris
I watch them back to back all right
up on um Ted lasso as well I forgot I
forgot I even dropped yeah yeah yeah the
whole no the whole thing's not out have
you seen my man play ball
like basketball
he can choose yeah he's done a couple
All-Star games
um and sometimes he's done like a he's
like you know sometimes actors will be
on court like pre-game or something yeah
he's pulled up a couple threes okay he's
Splash City bro okay yeah he's he's Wham
isn't it he's he just seems like the
coolest guy he does he's the coolest guy
um but yeah fair play bro so I didn't
I've been watching stuff it sounds like
it I'm jealous yeah but I've been I've
missed out though I've not watched off
in ages I started another one called or
the last thing he told me oh okay
um it's starring Jennifer Garner oh God
and Nikolai Costa this brother you know
this brother oh he's from Flippin is
Jamie Lannister
I've already seen a pilot but again
really good shots on TV just don't
advertise [__] brother
is already advertise if it's not on
Apple TV they're not advertising it yes
mad bro bangers we're just not hearing
about it you have to be on there yeah I
need to log back in I've logged in in a
minute neither have I bro that's what
I'm saying I'm happy I just went for it
movies bro okay but yeah um the last
thing he told me or whatever good show
as well I've only just started it but
it's really good as well Peng bro very
very very very painful so this one you
might have seen this one someone sent it
to me and the the thread is how strict
will your parents
I'll go first we weren't allowed to get
excited
[Laughter]
oh my God what allowed that I was
excited bro yeah yeah stuff like that
resonates
there was what brother I think I've got
a quite tweet of that specific tweet um
how strictly your parents I need to read
it as well as similar to the one you
just said how strict were your parents
if I have fun today I can't have fun
tomorrow
if I have friends today I can't have fun
bro that's Insanity bro wait resonate oh
it resonates bro me my brother weren't
allowed to get gassed over nothing
because my mom would turn around about
we won't go
we won't go we just won't leave the yard
yeah calm down
literally calm down I have time for it
facts bro you don't want to hear it and
on the drive there yeah shut up
compose yourself literally act like
you've been here before facts I like
you've been yeah if you want us to get
excited for nothing that's so hilarious
to me oh my God we couldn't get cast we
weren't allowed to be bouncing off the
walls yeah that's joking coughing at
night was a bit problematic I had to
cough internally so I wasn't being too
loud
oh yeah yeah bro yeah you can't make
that much noise you can't make that nice
noise bro I remember bro we used to have
like a little facts we used to have a
little sitting room downstairs right
yeah
um and it was kind of like the kids room
yes to be me my brother and when my step
sister and Stepbrother were around would
all be in that room and then we went
hard in the living room okay because my
mom's smoking in there no one's smoking
there she ain't going now yeah yeah yeah
he's cold fam yeah you can't hack the
smoke yeah this is my yard fam I used to
be in there just like she was like get
out your eyes are watering so much piss
off I'm not going outside of my own
house
facts bro she fully made the rules bro
she made every rule in the house bro and
then I remember one time on a Friday
night I'd stay up late and I'll be
watching TV in in the little back room
yeah and my mom's bedroom was directly
above it oh fam I'd hear a kick in the
thing turn it down turn it down bro
I remember it was on two oh yeah but
they I could barely hear it yeah but the
vibrations are still going up my mum's
stormed I was I can't hear her open her
door slam her door
slammed openness interview I [__]
told you to turn it down I'm like Mom
it's on two you can't hear it you can't
even hear it so I don't give a [__] turn
it down if I'm not to mute it as a
million put subtitles on
we have to meet in the middle what's all
of that about mutant subtitles live it
nah I was livid bro after me in the
middle I was living bro you won't have
to do [__] sorry vexed bro this one this
one resonates as well if I'm sick and I
laugh I have the strength to do any work
oh my God bro yes bro I big man I
remember when I um when I broke my
skateboard in my left hand yeah um
this was I was in year 13 maybe so I was
probably 17. I broke it and I had a
castle for three months obviously
there's only so much you can do when
you've got a class yeah yeah yeah
everybody was my left hand
um but I broke it during
um during school like during term and
obviously I went to a boarding school in
during college so when I came home for
like I can't remember the half term
holidays or whatever my mum was like I
don't think my sister was I think she
was still in uni so it was just me and
my mum okay
clean those dishes I was like Mom I
can't get this [__] wet yeah yeah she
was like you're lucky
she said you're lucky wow bro because
she she knew that she had no way out
yeah I literally couldn't get this wet
Sharon that's him like shower like this
you know I mean yeah yeah it was jarring
I was thinking to myself oh I can't wash
these dishes bro bro thank God I
remember when I was I remember I think I
told you there was one time I needed to
learn how to backflip
fam
this support is you know when you called
me a you earlier this supports that
narrative yeah I was tired of seeing
people being able to do backflips I just
couldn't do it backflip yeah so I was
like you know [__] this I'm doing it I'm
going to learn how to backflip bro yeah
so I put I bought my mattress down yeah
I know my duvet I put it in a garden yes
I remember and then one of the chairs
from the living room I was leaping off
that trying to do backflips on there
yeah long story short I broke my big toe
Baroque my big toe landed like that on
it yeah broke it I was like oh
it was hobbling hobbling my boy one of
my boy had crutches
and um I think I got like a bakkie on
his bike up to where we would play
football and I would just sit there and
this is my social time
fam could he needed a well I didn't
anticipate he wants his crutches back at
the end of the day
he's not letting me take them home he
said run me them back so I was like bro
I need that I need them bro and it was
like run me my crutches man like I don't
know what you want from me yeah and
where we used to play I was like a mile
from my house oh God so I'm like I've
got a broken toe I can't I don't know
what I'm gonna do so I bet my mom I said
I'm sorry Mom come and pick me up yeah
like I can't get home she's like what do
you mean you can't get home yeah I said
my toes broken I can't walk yeah she
said you should have thought about that
before you're doing backflips in the
back Garden
she said fam figure it out
you should have thought about that
before doing a backflip oh my family had
to walk like walk home like that for a
mile it took me hours
it took me hours but she didn't care
damn hair is a strict yeah if I'm it
doesn't matter if you've got a broken
toe it's based on how you broke your toe
fax though facts though yeah you should
have been doing foolishness facts though
crazy whenever snacks were bought at
home or anything we wouldn't normally
eat yeah unless something special
happened we'd always have to ask for
some and I'm talking wanting a cup of
juice but having to ask permission to
drink it
well okay that's that's what you're
gonna say just asking to take snacks
yeah to do that as a year yeah if I went
to like a little tree or sweets or
something I have to ask but to ask to
drink juice yeah
that's that's concentration the facts
that's something else my brother used to
back the juice
he's the back to juice and eat all the
yogurts my mom you end mental remember
he used to eat all of yours [__] he
would eat a whole pot of yogurt and [__]
himself he didn't care he'd run right
next to him eat a whole another one my
mom used to go mental
and [__] himself bro oh my problem was a
tyrant in the yard that's jokes he had
back all the fruits yeah man yoga's what
I think yeah mine was the Maryland
cookies bro wow it's a throwback [__]
cookies today it's such a shitty cookie
but back then after four hours of
football I needed the calories bro that
was good I needed all the calories I
used to smash her a whole packet my mom
used to go Mentor four hours of football
well my mom used took her mental [__]
you know right one I wasn't allowed to
watch TV during the day as a result I
have little to no reference of cartoons
my dad would actually check the TV
temperature when he got home from work
now what is what I'm talking about his
hand on the back of the TV
yeah yeah he had a [__] off back before
yeah wow wow wow wow wow temperature of
the TV yeah facts if you didn't want to
you don't have me
you're just punishing me for being alive
Jesus number two had to come home
straight after school to do homework and
just sit there
the worst thing bro God yeah yeah that's
the end of it vile bro absolutely vile
it's not fair parents don't care
sometimes Mom oh they actually don't bro
because they're punishing you for just
breathing facts but for just being a
happy kid yeah 100 because they have
PTSD of not being a happy kid 100 so
they're like you man don't know how good
you've got it 100 so let me show you how
bad it was for me that's exactly what it
was like when my mum made me get a job
oh when I was 16. yeah yeah she was like
you need money get a job I was like I
promise you I don't need money I'd
rather be broke
what do I want I don't eat sweets yeah
I'd rather not have a job and not eat
sweets yeah yeah yeah then have a job
and have all the sweets I want I'm not
getting a job she was like when I was a
kid I beg my dad for a job and he would
never let me because it would [__] with
his benefits yeah I had no money I was
broke I couldn't do nothing you're
getting a job and I was like big man
please no yeah
just I don't want the job man bro forced
me bro of course they forced me bro it's
a life on you like they they want you to
feel some form of torture so that when
you get out of it when you reach the
other side you're like oh thank you blah
blah no man let me play [__] let me play
bro yeah I went to bed at 8pm on a
Saturday
because it was 8 P.M summer the kids
were out and the sun was a team I told
you my dad said the same thing 10
o'clock doesn't matter how hard it's
teeth time bro you need a routine
I said definitely
I'm 16. bro
did you translate this time bro team
time was the bane of me
he didn't care Oh team time and bug
attacks bro every time he bought his
Burgers mama said tax he wants to teach
us business ethics from early okay man
if I'm here take us to Burger King on a
Friday after like after the changeover
yeah my mom would drop us yeah he'll
pick us up it's too late to be in dinner
so take us to Burger King fam I'll get
my Double Whopper man will say tax he
won't even look back he'll say tax and
just put his hand back yeah
my burger well so you can say goodbye so
you can take 20 percent
laughs
nah I'm a child
what are you talking about me my v-80
tax I need to take a bite these are mine
yeah he's a man it'd take a bite bro
I'll buy the bug on a handful of chicks
and I said that's tax oh even when I had
friends in the car he'd say tax so I had
to say Dad you're not bite his Burger
take two of mine
take two bites of mine and my dad will
say say less you're lucky
I just did you want to take your friends
Burgers yeah I just eat though no no no
no no he's running his attacks from me
he's taking his tax from he's taking his
tax from Lawrence and then my boy Lewis
will be in the car not to lose you know
one of my boys from school come over for
a sleepover
I can't have him go to school tomorrow
and tell everyone my dad was listening
up his burger just take two advice on my
ex because if I'm losing parents I'm
coming to the yard fax what do you mean
you sucked on his Burger bro I had to
dash in my Whopper for a second bite my
dad kisses to even take a bigger bite
give me nothing left bro I'm so angry I
said tax no I was drawing oh you've
never told me
attacks was a [__] bro wow that's funny
that's funny bro he's trying to teach us
lessons we didn't want to learn
wow he's saying life is not Rosy fam
life's not right nothing comes for free
facts bro run me my 20 oh that's
hilarious oh so hilarious man goodness
me all right just to finish off got a uh
trash news I hit me bro cool right this
one you I know you've been saying this
more than me I already know what it is
no way is but I'm here for you let's go
I'm not ready
Hotel manager
[Laughter]
everyone knows what this is bro Hotel
manager charged after a guest woke up to
him sucking his toes listen to me listen
a Tennessee Hotel manager is facing
charges after sneaking into a guest room
and sucking on their toes
according to Nashville police 52 year
old David Neal was arrested after he
snuck into a male guest room while he
was sleeping and got intimate on his
foot Jesus Christ the guest tells police
that he woke up to David's mouth wrapped
around his toes not even one toe
and immediately confronted him
the guest says he recognized the mass
the manager as an employee who had
entered his room the day before to help
so even solve an issue with the TV oh my
God David was a night manager at the
Hilton in Nashville at the um at the
time of the incident and he made a key
card before entering the room around 5
a.m
that's crazy bro I promise you now my
screen will be so loud only dogs would
hear it bro so high pitched only dogs
would hear it listen I couldn't wake up
to that my body's not defrosted yet so I
wouldn't know how to like express myself
you wake up you look down and then
matters oh and there's a spit a spit
string between your toe and it might
just and it's not even a sink there's
toes bro so you feel it
he's a night manager man the fact that
he went there the night before to fix
something I was like I found my prey for
tonight facts while he saw fam and he
saw those toys before I was like and
said that's me tomorrow night yum I
promise you that's me tomorrow night oh
that's that's stuff I can't even fathom
bro I couldn't wake up to that bro oh
I'll be crying my eyes out there need
money one of those tinfall blankets over
me when the police comes oh facts I'm
shaking wrap me up
wrap me up because that's that's PTSD
damage
I made I've never sleep in a hotel again
in fact the Hilton as well not even like
us on roadside Motel yeah Hilton man
made himself a card and snuck in see
that I'd beat him to death
listen to me I'll beat him to death
if you had after I've overcome the fear
I've just screamed
and he's like perked up and tried to run
yeah once I realized what's happening
I'm wiping my foot on the covers and I'm
dying after him
let go was he done
what are you gonna say what's he done
because I'll be too embarrassed to tell
him what's done he knows what he's done
I mean I ask him ask him what he did ask
him what he did and he's gonna he's
gonna lie obviously fam I smell smoke
I came as if you were right
I wasn't sucking nothing I'll beat him
to death oh facts bro I'll never see
another day yeah that um because I need
I need closure yeah you need something I
need clothes you can't just get away
with it facts bro just get you can't
arrest him and give him a fine yeah and
tell him to go on he's a predator he is
bro yeah I need him off the streets
because I won't sleep safe again toes
bro
male toes bro you man if your hotel has
that extra lock-ish
yeah give it yeah you need that what's
that two two facts authentication
in fact authentication
yeah two-step very bro you can't have my
goodness Bree that's um that's some
scary hours bro
goodness me I'll cry bro so would I I
it's also Peak because
I can't let this information get out I
can't let you man riddle me facts bro
Riddle Me ridicule me
because you're obviously and the thing
is in our friendship group I know it'd
be Jacob as well yeah people like why do
you think you picked you fat bro he was
yeah because obviously he thought you're
a [__] you will break it down so much
and and I will feel like right yeah so
I'll actually feel like the brain I'm
like raw he actually chose he chose me
and I I wouldn't be able to sleep bro
facts bro I wouldn't be able to I
couldn't I couldn't look you man in the
eye because I know all your men are
thinking about it that's all you men are
thinking about fam [__] sakito sakito
you little dainty little toe let me see
that yeah let me see what you're wearing
let me see that dainty little princess
yeah let me see what he wanted to start
what's this is just male foot yeah yeah
he could never want to suck my toe I've
been working
I've been putting bread on the table
yeah you got time
oh yeah that little [__] let me see
that oh my goodness yeah I'm smacking
everyone yeah there was not getting out
it couldn't keep me anonymous
yeah that's um that's bravery at another
level yeah 100 I don't know what he
expected to get away with I lied because
short the thing is right he's this is
not the first time he's done this
obviously facts but how
how is he won how is he finding his prey
and two how is no one else waking up or
like how is he trying to how is he
escaping because he can't put lights on
yeah I'm deep I'm deep in it now I'm
deep in it he's coming in he must have
you know them ones where like you've got
a gunner you've got a Torchlight as well
so he's like he's like he's prepped yeah
he's gone flash on flash off yeah yeah
so he can scope the area yeah obviously
man's got the blueprint already yeah
yeah but he's flash on flash off the
scope to see if the suitcases on the
floor whatever flash on flash off
getting closer and closer flash on flash
off yeah getting closer and closer and
it's one of them ones as well he's
altered the [__]
um aircon aircon he's altered it so
you're a bit too cold but you're warm at
the same time you're warm so your toes
are right out your toes are right you've
got one leg out one leg in his life
you go one for out and one for him he
doesn't care if he's left or right he's
ambidextrous in this [__] he doesn't
care his pink is ambidextrous
bro and he's been perfect torch on Torch
off let me get closer yeah and he just
he just gets on his knees bro he
literally gets on his knees to put your
[__] toe in his mouth bro and that's
first of all livid because another
question that the Mandan will be asking
is
Man actually flipped the whole thing in
his mouth what size are you what size
are you secondly
another reason why I'm going to beat him
to death yeah is because he took my
favorite position from me
because now I can't go one yeah now I
need to be covered at all times that's
PTSD sweating through the night I'm
having night sweats because I can't cool
down because David knew was lips in my
foot bottom see that
and how long does he if okay obviously
he got caught today but the times he's
been doing it how long is he there for
this is what's the satisfaction barrier
you know what I mean bro it's not his
first time that's what I'm saying I know
he's nice that's how we got confident to
put the whole thing in his mouth because
no one's been waking up yeah that's what
tipped him over there yeah because it
started he started with a pinky yeah and
ran out yes
I thought that was a rush that was a
rush yeah he probably unlocked it he put
the card in came up came through
no one no one he couldn't hear anything
yeah close it that's enough for today
tomorrow you get my step and steps
lips one pinking for Jesus Jesus run out
fat in the back office wow that's a rush
that's a rush I can't wait for my shift
tomorrow night yeah yeah
fix homeboys TV and saw those yeah I
thought yeah that's that's my target
[__] that's a snack that's not a whole
foot tonight I'm taking that whole foot
and he just crept in crept in his
literally grabbed it calling the fam
concaved it and stopped it in his mouth
I couldn't feel that yeah my man said
I'll scream so loud only dog's kid dogs
would hear me bro same
actually tear my voice found the thing
is that my emotion yeah yeah roller
coaster because I will scream yeah
fear yeah blanket here scream as loud as
I can yeah and then break down crying
for about three seconds because I can't
believe what's going on yeah yeah and
then anger like you've never experience
yeah yeah and as soon as I see him
running I'm thinking
come here because it's one of them ones
where you you start to deep was he just
after the foot yeah or he won or was the
foot just just to start yeah done
anything else to me you start looking at
your body oh fam um
I'll be there and I'll be looking for
not I'll be in there looking for
something I'm looking for something and
I'm sweating it
is there any foreign bodies in here I'm
looking for not so I'm not smelling my
breath everything bro yeah you decide
what did you do what else did you do
yeah yeah but what else did you do
bro because there's there's oh my God
yeah there's too many there's I don't
think we can continue but there's too
many yeah there's just too much going on
um but anyway guys we're gonna wrap it
there thank you for today's episode this
has been blessed thank you for everyone
tuning in thank you everyone who came to
see us live and as always guys head on
over to patreon for more of that good
good and uh yeah man love love
[Music]